this movie takes place and is coming up
40 years after the original Halloween
which is 20 years after Halloween h2o
Halloween h2o being the movie that took
place and came out 20 years after the
original Halloween one of this is to
illustrate the fact that the gap of time
between the original Halloween and h2o
is the same gap of time between
Halloween h2o and now I remember seeing
Halloween h2o in theaters the time
passage in my parents Minds between the
original Halloween and h2o when it came
out is the same as Halloween h2o and
mine now I'm not even high right now I'm
just saying times a crazy thing I feel
oldest [ __ ] hug me
[Music]
Halloween that's all it's called it's
not to or anything so this Halloween is
the official and only sequel to the John
Carpenter Halloween that came out 40
years ago Laurie Strode had a bumpy road
since the Michael Meyers murders of 40
years ago Michael Myers hasn't spoken a
word because he never does then he gets
out and this is the night he came home
again and I really dug this movie this
was a celebration of what made the
original Halloween great first of all
they treat Michael Myers as Michael
Myers was originally treated as a serial
killer who escaped and now he's killing
people in fact the first half of this
movie is a complete ode to the original
Halloween the original Halloween like is
it really a slasher movie original
Halloween is preying on that concept
that phobia that thought we've all had
for walking down a dark road we look
into the woods and you feel like
someone's watching you but you don't
know if it's true or not in fact it
probably isn't Halloween showed us yeah
it's true Michael Myers is looking at
you that was the creepy part of the
original Halloween and that's where this
movie really shines
it's the staring at a distance it's the
prowling it's that creepy breathing he
does under his mask I love those shots
where it's an outside shot looking into
a house and you just hear the breathing
you don't see Michael Myers you just
hear it that's what made Halloween
Halloween and that's what a lot of those
Halloween sequels were missing but
killers aren't that elaborate either
people die in this movie sure but for a
long while it's just like thud knock
them over the head stab them it's not
torture porn it's not a gore now I mean
Gore comes in the second half of the
movie for sure I'm not gonna deny it but
because it hadn't happened until the
second half of the movie when it does
happen it's really shocking not like I
seen it whatever it's all just feels
more gratifying that way for a lot of
kills you don't even see the kill happen
you just see the aftermath of the kill
because if the main fear and
entertainment is watching the kill
happened let's just shock the main thing
is holy [ __ ] he was in this house and
someone's now dead it's the fear of not
knowing I love the fact that this movie
did that also I really liked Laurie
Strode and Hollywood here's how you make
a strong female character back here's
how you make a strong character in
general Laurie Strode is not completely
perfect at everything she's not fearless
in the sense of absence of fear she's
not strong in the sense of absence of
weakness she's fearless because she's
scared to death to go up against Michael
Myers but she does she's strong because
she is choosing to go up against this
boogey man who in her mind's eye is the
boogey man this guy messed her up she's
not flawless she has a lot of flaws
she's a agoraphobic but through that
fear which she still feels she's
channeled that to become some warrior
who
like all right when he comes back I'm
going to go after him I love the fact
that Laurie Strode in this movie is
flawed very human very traumatized yet
very strong it shows us the
psychological aftermath of a serial
killer killing your friends and coming
after you the movie isn't without its
flaws or horror movie cliches people are
still morons in this movie I mean there
are some idiots like hey there's a
serial killer on the loose we all know
who he is and what he's capable of with
that cop car that just drove up here is
not answering the radio maybe I should
go up to it and investigate and there's
this doctor in here like not dr. Loomis
that might as well be his name they even
say in here Jamie Lee Curtis is like
you're the next Loomis which is pretty
much how you feel he is he's in here
because they need a doctor in here
because there was a doctor in the last
one and there's this weird little side
arc that I feel is supposed to ask
questions about insanity and in the end
I'm like I just don't care this is not
your movie man I don't care the
questions you have about Michael Myers I
don't care that you're really fascinated
with him get back to Laurie this was
like her movie and her family's movie
but we actually had some humor in it too
I enjoyed the humor for the most part
the humor didn't compromise the movie
little kid in particular was hysterical
he just made me laugh but at one point I
was like he probably should be more
scared out of your mind right now rather
than cracking a joke so I felt like that
was a little out of place since he's a
little kid and this is a knife wielding
psychopath it looks pretty scary for the
most part didn't compromise the movie as
long as in the end I really dug this
Halloween movie if you don't like the
original Halloween you probably won't
like this movie it's like this movie was
made for fans of the original Halloween
it's the legit sequel to the original
Halloween that makes an effort to show
the audience it knows and respects where
it comes from and I'll say Halloween is
worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray all by I'll have Halloween and
its sequel Halloween funny the original
Michael Myers mask was actually a
William Shatner mask that they painted
white you learned that tidbit you're
like is that true holy [ __ ] it totally
is so I guess 40 years later the masks
should probably look something like this
gotta tell ya it's not far off
I saw Halloween have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]